είμαν της παραπαιδίας εδώ και το πιο σημαντικό το παιδί να αγαπάτω σχολείων το έχουμε
χάσει τούτον τον πράγμε οι δικά στις μεγάλες ηλιγίες είναι πολύ πανενω να βρις παιδί
μου να σοπει ναι αγααπό το σχολείο προχθέσι νοήμου σε μια καφετέρια με προς έγκισε
ενελαγκορι τσάκι και το είπενημητέρα του δεν ξερω ότι με υπουργός παιδίας και μου λέει
θέλω να βγάλουμε φωτογραφεία καιρό τησαμε το το παιδί που είσεσε ολογήμερο σχολείο μου λε
τις λέω οαρέσει στον λμερο και αβάντηση ήταν το όλα τρέβω και άλλάμπάντα μάτια της
μαλέω πρέπει να αμπορέσω να διατηρίσω τοτη τη λάμψη μέχρει να τελειώσει η μικριαλίκη μου
είπε να λέω το όνομεαντης γι αυτό το λέω και που είπε να βάλει στο
όνομα μυτα θα βαλίστικδογραφεία και το έκαμα άρα ο στόχος μας είναι να διατηρήσουν ττη
λάμψεη την αγνήστα παιδιά για να το κάμουμε τούτο πρέπει να έουμε εκπαιδευτικούς με βάθος
με αγάπη για τη δουλειά τους και επιστεύω όπως η περισσότερι ίδη το έχουν αυτόνλλά
το έχου χάσει και μέσα από το σύστημα να ξιολόγησης που έχουμε το ισοποιεδο ότικών
ενόλη άριστη ακριβώς αραπρέπει αυτά να τα αλλάζουμε σιασικά και είναι γι αυτόν τον λόγο
που δουλεπουμε επειδή επάτε όλοι άριστη δημοσιαπηρεσία γι θυνά μηχαελίδου δέέχετα παρεμβάσεις όταν υπάρξει μια
μετάθεση όταν υπάρξει αλλάγη ε σχολεί πως τοβιώνι ίσα ταν μέρος ναι τι μέωσιας υπηρεσίας
ξέρετε πως δουλεύει επειδή κάνετε πολλές αλλαγες ίσως υπάρξει μια αλλαγή και πάνωσε αυτόν τα
θέμα κοιτάξετε γιαμένα είναι πιο εύκολον να απορίψωτούτες τις παρεμβάσεις γιατί γνωρίζω ότις διαδικασίες υπάρχουν
όμως ντονα και σε αυτό το πως των τις έχοβιώσει τις βιών είναι όμως με
τη δικήσου ότη πρακτική που θα καταλάβουν οι γύρωσου ο πιο ρόλον κια αν έχουν
και θέσ κι αν έχουν ότι δεν μπορεί να περάσει αυτό υπάρχουν κανονισμεί σε μας
ευτυχώς στηνας